[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAMERON STRANG: Thank you to
Google for having me here.
And that's not a sentence
that historians really
get to say very often.
Thank you, Google.
It's a very surprising
pleasure to get to present
at a place like this.
And not only is it I probably
had the best cup of tea
of my life at the new upstairs
cafeteria a little while ago,
but for me and I think
lots of Americans,
Google is the cutting
edge of science, right?
This is where American science
is going in the future.
So I think it's a
really interesting place
to talk about where
American science came from
and what its origins were, its
character in the early United
States before we've gotten
to where we are now.
And I'm certainly not
the first historian
to ask this kind of question.
But as with so many questions,
right, the answer really
depends on where you look.
And nearly everyone
who's researched this
has sought answers
to this question
in places like Philadelphia,
Boston, Cambridge.
And in some ways, this
makes sense, right?
These cities had some of the
best scientific institutions
and universities
in Anglo America,
and they were also places
that had vital roles
in the American Revolution.
And this coincidence
allowed historians
to tell a really
convenient story,
one in which
knowledge and freedom
emerged together
in America, right?
And historians have loved
to tell this story that
what made American science
distinct in the early United
States was this new context
of liberty and democracy
that supposedly emerged
with the revolution.
But it doesn't take a
geographer to figure out
that the United States was much
more than this Northeastern
Anglo fringe.
The basic argument in my
book is that American science
looks a lot different
when we include
the rest of the country.
Really, the vast
majority of the country.
But it was not
liberty and democracy
that most influenced
intellectual lives
for the diverse Americans living
throughout this territory.
And throughout this
huge range, there
were natives, African-descended
peoples, Creoles,
French, Spanish all of this,
all of whom studied nature.
But they did so in ways that
were not influenced most
by this context of
liberty and democracy
that we like to think about
as characterizing early US
science.
In these places, it was
imperialism, inequality,
and violence that most
defined how people
studied the natural world.
This is because imperialism
did not disappear
from North America after 1776.
Instead, the American Revolution
created a new imperial power,
one that was eager to
expand across the continent.
And Americans don't really
like to think about the United
States as imperial.
But it really did all
the same kind of stuff
that other empires do.
It used diplomacy
and military force
to conquer new territories.
It used local cooperators on
the ground to get things done.
And it enforced
these hierarchies
of differences, hierarchies
of inequality based on place,
based on race.
So despite the fact
that Americans today
love to view 1776 as this
sudden shift from imperialism
to liberty, people throughout
most of the United States
did not experience it this way.
Instead, they experienced this
as an era of US expansion,
of yet another phase in a
much longer, older history
of European imperialism
in North America-- one
that goes back to
the early 1500s.
So my book argues that it was
this persistence of imperialism
and not the rise of
liberty that made science
in the early United
States what it was.
And it's because just
as in European empires,
US imperialism led to
encounters-- encounters
with new places, encounters
with new peoples, all of which
affected how people studied
and applied the knowledge
they developed about nature.
And across the
chapters in this book,
I discuss this through
sciences like geology,
and natural history, and
botany, and ethnology.
But for today's talk, I
want to focus on astronomy.
And I do so for
a couple reasons.
First of all is
that astronomy was
absolutely central, essential
to imperial expansion.
It's because European and,
eventually, US astronomers,
they measured the heavens
to determine their location
on Earth, the location
of important spots
to run international
boundary lines
and to draw maps, all of
which depended on the stars
and were essential to creating
legitimate land claims.
So before Google
Maps, right, if you
wanted to know where
you were precisely,
you needed astronomy,
especially if you
wanted to claim that land as
yours or part of your nation.
Second, astronomers
were able to turn
the individual observations
they'd make of the heavens
into accurate maps
and other things
because they shared data across
these robust national and
international networks.
You get a sense of one of these
sort of compilations of data
there with the
chart on the right.
And since I'm presenting
here at Google,
the exchange of data and
the creation of data network
seems like a really
interesting topic.
And I'd really be
interested in the Q&A
to discuss how the kind of
networks I'm outlining here
are similar or different
to those for which Google
is such a hub now.
And third, while at
first blush astronomy
might seem like one of
the sciences most removed
from life on Earth,
in fact, I'd say
that it offers a really
good window into the wider
world of early America.
That's because astronomy
in the early United States
was a tool of
expansion, depended
on slavery and
violence, was vital
to these geopolitical
and cultural competitions
among empires.
It was a means of
claiming Indian lands.
And because astronomy reveals
that then as much as now,
really, astronomy
in the United States
was thoroughly multinational
and transnational.
One of the first places where
astronomy and US expansion
overlapped was in the Gulf
South, the region that's
now the states of Louisiana,
Mississippi, Alabama,
and Florida.
When the US won independence
from Britain in 1783,
all of this was part
of the Spanish empire.
But US officials really
coveted this region.
For one, they wanted
New Orleans because it
was this hub of trade between
the interior of the continent
and the whole Atlantic Ocean.
And also because all
of this territory
seems like prime plantation
land for expanding slavery,
getting super rich off
cotton in particular.
They had first started acquiring
parts of this region in 1795.
By the early 1800s,
they had it all.
This expansion was
very successful,
and it was the
first of many times,
of course, that the
United States would expand
at Spanish America's expense,
something that's been going on
into the 20th century.
So looking at astronomy
in this region
reveals a lot of the ways
that astronomy promoted
Anglo American imperialism.
And perhaps most
importantly, it shows
that Anglos did not simply
export scientific practices
from the east into the west.
Instead, these things
developed through encounters
in the region.
And these are encounters
among Anglos and Spaniards,
between masters and slaves,
and between whites and Indians.
The earliest such
encounters occurred
during the Florida
boundary survey, which
was run from 1798 to 1800.
You can see on the top of
the map there on the left,
the line ran along the
31st parallel of latitude
for hundreds of miles.
And a few of the boundary
stones still remain.
But on the south
side of the stone,
it said property of
King Carlos IV of Spain.
Northern side of the rock said
property of the United States.
And since this was a
massive and really important
astronomical
expedition, we're going
to spend a little bit of time
digging into it as this window
into early American astronomy.
But astronomy was more
than just the means
to a geographic and
geopolitical end.
It wasn't only
creating this boundary,
this line in the sand.
It was a field of competition
between Spain and the US.
And both sides really
used this as a chance
to express national
pride and really compete
with each other for prestige.
And also, part of the
reason this line was created
was that Spanish
and US officials
wanted to try to bring order
to this region, this very
chaotic border region where
they have little control.
But the line itself actually
did more than actually
just prove the
messiness of this place,
a place with very confusing
ethnic and national
relationships.
For instance, Anglos
ended up working
for both the US and Spanish
Astronomical Commissions.
Indians ended up working
both to protect and destroy
this survey.
And both sides ended up
relying on black slaves.
So to take a step
backwards briefly,
Spain obviously had
the longer tradition
of using astronomy in the
service of imperialism here.
Going back 300
years, it had been
crucial to navigators who
explored Spain's huge empire
and to the cartographers
who tried to map it.
And a lot of these explorers
were often pictured
as astronomers, that astronomers
were these kind of heroes
of the empires, right, who used
the heavens to claim the earth.
And astronomy really
remained a source of pride
for Spanish officials going
into the era of the Florida
boundaries survey.
The governor of
Louisiana, a guy named--
Spanish Louisiana,
I should say--
Manuel Gayoso de Lemos, he
chose the astronomer he did,
a guy named William Dunbar,
a local plantation owner,
because he said if I don't
get an excellent astronomer
like Dunbar, I'll be laughed at.
This was really considered
a source of pride.
And if gone wrong, shame, right?
That astronomy was
caught up in all
of these national
competitions for prestige.
As in Spain and other
European empires,
astronomy was a source
of both expansion
and national pride in
the early United States.
For instance, right after
winning independence in 1783,
there was an Anglo
astronomer who
wrote that the extensive
territories of the United
States are a foundation in
nature for a vast empire.
And to know its geography and
fix the interesting boundaries
and lines, the best
and only proper method
is that of astronomical
observations.
So from the very
beginning, they're
thinking of ways to use
astronomy to promote expansion.
Also, as in Spain,
astronomy was a source
of national pride and identity.
And one of the ways
you can see this
is in the early star
charts, these maps
of constellations that are
produced in the United States.
These came up with new
distinctly American
constellations.
On the left, there's a picture
of the bust of Columbus.
My favorite on the right,
the flying squirrel,
which you can still see up
near Perseus in the sky.
Both patriotism and
imperialism would
mark the astronomical
work of the commission
of US astronomers
who went down to run
this boundary between
Spain and the United
States along the 31st parallel.
The leader of this
expedition was an astronomer
named Andrew Ellicott.
And for one, this
expedition gave him
a chance to experiment with
new methods of doing astronomy
in the field, especially
methods that are ideally
suited to this land-based empire
that the United States was
building.
So astronomers at the time,
and today, really believed
that to do credible
astronomy depended
on being detached and
isolated from the influences
of the world, right?
Something that was
best achieved in
these closed-off observatories
and well-controlled spaces.
And we still have this image
of science today, right?
That doing credible
science depends
on being in these strictly
controlled spaces.
Think of coming in here.
You have to go to the desk
with your ID cards and such.
And imagine trying to
do your work in a place
where just anyone
could walk around
and start touching on
your keyboard and such.
This idea of political
control to doing good science
remains very crucial.
So one of Andrew Ellicott's
goals during this survey
was to figure out how
to produce this kind
of idealized detachment in
the midst of a place that
was poorly controlled
politically and still
very wild in terms of
nature, and wild animals,
and all of this.
As he put it, despite the
efforts of France, Britain,
and Spain to tame this
region, the country
is yet in a state of infamy.
And so he aimed to,
quote, "determine
by experiment what
reliance might
be placed on observatories
made at temporary stations
without any of the
conveniences annexed
to permanent observatories."
If he had thought
he could achieve
this kind of
detachment, Ellicott
was sorely disappointed.
He constantly complained
about the weather
destroying his very
expensive instruments
and mosquitoes harassing
him, so he couldn't actually
concentrate on
his observations--
and also, human
sabotage, which we'll
talk about in a little bit.
So this reminds us, for one,
that humans doing science,
right, are never really isolated
from the world around them,
even though they'd like to
think of themselves that way.
And this is especially true
in places that are poorly
controlled places like these
unruly frontier regions
in particularly.
Ellicott also found that
his social world was really
impeding his effort to
do credible astronomy
during this survey.
For reasons that are
still very unclear,
one of the other astronomers
that was working with him
accused Ellicott of
having threesomes
with his washerwoman
and his own son, who
is also an assistant
on this expedition.
And even more
strangely, Ellicott
deflected these attacks by
accusing the Spanish people who
believed them of being
unscientific and bad
astronomers.
As he put it, these
insinuations would
have but little weight with the
people of the United States.
But the case is very
different with the Spaniards,
naturally jealous and uninformed
in science, particularly so far
as it relates to
astronomical observations.
He didn't really explain how
he gets from defending himself
from charges of sexual
deviance to accusing Spaniards
of being bad at astronomy.
But this rhetorical move
does suggest something
about how much Anglos' national
pride and prejudice really
cohered at these
frontiers of encounter.
So Ellicott wasn't just drawing
a kind of territorial boundary
in Florida, right?
He was drawing a
national boundary,
one that distinguished
Anglo Americans as peoples
with distinct traits.
And this characterization that
he makes, right, of the United
States and its citizens of a
scientific people in contrast
to those of Latin
America very much
remains part of national
discourse today.
So the US astronomer Andrew
Ellicott and the astronomer
for Spain's commission,
William Dunbar,
their observations of stars,
planets, the moon, the sun,
moons of planets,
these were all used
to fix the position
of this boundary line.
But all of this
astronomical work
wouldn't have been
possible without the work
of enslaved blacks.
Black laborers carried
all this equipment
that needed to be carried.
They cut down hundreds of trees
to make it actually possible
to see the heavens
through the dense forests
of the southeastern
United States.
And a lot of this work was done
in the middle of these swamps
and bayous.
You couldn't control you
where you went, right?
You had to stay on
that latitude line.
So extremely dangerous
and hard work,
and work that the white
employees of these commissions
all got too sick to do from
the very beginning, really.
So to put it simply,
this boundary
line we think of as
a work of astronomy,
but it simply could not have
been done without slave labor.
And at root, enslaved
labor depends
on violence, the
willingness of masters
to hurt people to make
them work for them, right?
And this use of slave labor
is really just one of the ways
that science hinged on violence
in the early United States.
It's really common
to think of science
as this kind of essentially
peaceful activity.
And this is part of the
appeal of science, right?
We think of it as this
peaceful detached thing.
In the early United States-- and
I'd argue much more broadly--
knowledge production
often depended
on various forms of
violence, from slavery
to direct military conquests
and even things like desecrating
and mutilating dead bodies.
Anyway, the US and Spain split
the cost of hiring 24 slaves.
Here's a list of one of
the records of these slave
employees that the
Spanish commission kept.
The money, of course, wasn't
paid to the slaves themselves.
It was paid to their masters
to rent out their work.
And William Dunbar,
Spain's astronomer,
was himself a very
rich slave owner.
And he used these slaves most
heavily during the survey.
And one of the reasons he
did so was using slave labor
as a way to transpose the
kind of order and discipline
of his plantation onto these
otherwise poorly controlled
spaces of the fieldwork.
Remember how Andrew
Ellicott tried and failed
to order these spaces through
his temporary experimental
observatories.
Dunbar had a lot more success
in this quest for control
because he was able to
use torture and violence
to recreate order
and discipline.
By disciplining people, he was
able to do disciplined science.
In fact, Dunbar would find this
to be such a successful method
that in his
correspondence with Thomas
Jefferson over the coming
years, he consistently
advocated that Jefferson
use enslaved laborers
for Western expeditions
like Lewis and Clark,
instead of sending
Anglo Americans.
So the violent coercion
of enslaved laborers
was able to get this
line progressing.
But they were ultimately unable
to complete the survey because
of violence against
them, violence
coming from local natives.
As the commission worked, it
started around the Mississippi
River and worked east.
And as it worked
east towards Florida,
they ran into lands dominated
by Creek and Seminole Indians,
who very much resented
what this survey was doing
because a lot of
their influence came
from being able to play
Spanish and US powers off
against each other, right?
And they feared that if this
clear boundary line were run
and jurisdictions
were made more clear,
they'd lose this kind
of between status that
gave them such flexibility.
So there was a threat
of armed violence
to ending this expedition.
And one of the ways that
the expedition members tried
to overcome this
threat was actually
hiring different
natives as bodyguards.
Groups of Upper Creeks got
paid by the commissioners
to travel with them and
protect them from attacks
by other Creeks and Seminoles.
This is, again, a
list of employees.
These are the chiefs and
bodyguards of the Creek Nation
hired by Spain.
A lot of other
natives, though, chose
to try to thwart this expedition
instead of support it.
And some did so by
non-violent means.
Some stole the
expedition's horses
and scientific instruments.
And these weren't actually
just random thefts--
they seem to have
chosen instruments
that they knew
would prevent them
from completing this boundary.
They stole Ellicott's artificial
horizon, an instrument
that you need to
determine latitude.
And you can't finish
this line if you
can't determine latitude.
And Ellicott actually
grumbled that, as he put it,
an impertinent young Indian
kept moving the minute hand
on his clock, which made
it impossible to determine
longitude.
Still, the most effective form
of opposition to the survey
was armed resistance.
And the surveyors
eventually encountered
a force of hundreds
of Seminoles,
and as Ellicott put
it, they compelled
us to relinquish our design
and leave the country.
So despite efforts by
Spain and the United States
to use this survey as
a chance to show off
their national
pride and power, it
was actually Indian power on
the ground that determined
its ultimate success.
For one, this is an
important reminder
of who was still actually
in charge in this region.
It was still Indian country.
But it also shows
some of the other ways
that science could
hinge on violence.
It would be 20 years in some
places, 40 in this region,
before the United
States had done enough
of a military conquest
that they controlled
those spaces enough
to do science in ways
they saw as credible and safe.
And this would keep going
throughout the expansion
into the west, too, where
people studying everything
from natural history
to astronomy either
were preceded by
the US Army often
or were embedded with
them, that a lot of time,
these forces of soldiers
out in the west fighting
Indians and Mexicans had
naturalists, and astronomers,
and geologists with them,
who were taking advantage
of the safety provided by them.
So by the late 1790s,
the United States
had joined these European
empires, like France, Britain,
Spain, and competed to control
this geopolitically valuable
region in the Gulf South.
And like these other
empires, the United States
relied on local
cooperation to do this.
Simply none of these
empires had enough power
to just send in their own
people and control these.
They needed people on the ground
as local experts, local power
brokers.
And one of the most
influential of these guys
was the astronomer
William Dunbar.
He had held plantations
in West Florida--
what's now the little
toe on Louisiana
sticking east of the
Mississippi River--
from during the eras of British,
Spanish, and ultimately,
US rule.
But far from being
a patriot for any
of these different
countries, he really
thrived by switching
allegiances among them,
and sometimes holding these
allegiances simultaneously.
And this portrait of Dunbar,
the guy in the middle, it's
hanging up in Natchez now.
And the story behind
it is actually
that when it was
originally painted,
he had a red coat because
Britain was in charge
of West Florida at the time.
But after the region
fell under US control,
he had this repainted
to have a black coat,
like a distinguished Republican.
Literally a turncoat, right?
And here we see another
way that looking
at the rest of the country gives
us a different look at science
in the early United
States, that one
of the things that historians
have almost all agreed on
is that a kind of
shared patriotism
made American
science what it was.
But throughout most
of the country,
these people had ambivalent
allegiances at least,
and some of them were directly
hostile to US rule, right?
So Dunbar really became
a master of manipulating
imperial officials
and sort of having
this in-between status
between these empires in order
to improve his own
wealth and status.
And he made very
similar arguments
to the patrons of the officials
in these different empires
to get more money.
He told Gayoso de
Lemas, the governor
of Spanish Louisiana in
1798, as he was getting ready
for this Florida
boundary survey,
that he should get paid a lot
more than the US commission
because, quote,
"the high dignity
of a great and ancient monarchy,
when [? button ?] competition
with that of a newborn republic,
demands some distinction."
And this worked.
Gayoso gave him
an enormous raise,
gave him all of
this land, and even
gave him servants to attend
to him during the survey.
But this line itself actually
put Dunbar's plantation
outside of Natchez,
Mississippi, north
of the line in US territory.
And so Dunbar had to start
looking for similar patronage
from US officials.
And he had the most success
with President Thomas Jefferson.
In 1804, Jefferson hired
Dunbar as the leader
of two scientific expeditions,
offering him $3,000
compensation.
Dunbar was insulted.
He wanted more.
He told Jefferson that, quote,
"When a great empire talks
of compensation,
this ought to be
adequate to the importance
of the service and honorable
to the government and
to the individuals."
And just like Gayoso,
Jefferson fell for this play
on national pride and prestige.
And he upped Dunbar's pay.
He also knew that he
depended on him, right?
So these kind of
negotiations were
really typical of
how imperialism
had worked in the
Spanish empire,
like this contested place
where weak officials really
had to rely on local
cooperation if they
wanted to get anything done.
Individuals like
Dunbar had really
thrived in this system
of negotiated authority,
and they could continue
to do so under US rule
because the United States,
just like Spain, was,
as Dunbar put it,
this great empire that
also was overextended, also
relied on local cooperation.
So you can see from
examples like this
how Spanish ways of combining
science and imperialism
persisted into the
era of US rule.
And they did so
largely because of
the selfish and
self-interested actions
of guys like Dunbar, these
men of science on the ground.
So William Dunbar
and Thomas Jefferson,
they maintained this
correspondence for years
in the early 1800s.
And it's fascinating to see
how new scientific practices
emerged from their
exchange of letters
across these hundreds of miles.
In this sense, too,
the United States
was very similar to
European empires, where
scientific knowledge
didn't really
diffuse from Europe
to the world, right,
but actually
emerged in this kind
of back-and-forth conversation
between colonies and metro
poles.
So for instance,
Jefferson and Dunbar
developed together a new
method of determining longitude
on land through astronomy,
one that was ideally
suited for the US, this
kind of land-based empire
that the United
States was building.
So European empires,
at this time,
had really struggled
with [INAUDIBLE] question
of how to find longitude at sea.
It was a challenge
that was solved
right around this
[INAUDIBLE] moment
by a guy named John Harrison,
who basically invented
a really, really good clock
that could be carried on ships.
But for the US, finding
the longitude at sea
wasn't as important as
being able to do so on land.
After all, they were building
this land-based empire.
So what Jefferson
really wanted was a way
that a single explorer traveling
with sturdy, cheap instruments
could find out their longitude
through observations.
You couldn't carry around one
of these Harrison chronometers
with you.
It would break.
It was big and heavy.
So this challenge
really came to the fore
as Jefferson starts planning
these western expeditions
after the Louisiana Purchase,
things like the Lewis and Clark
expedition.
And Jefferson starts consulting
astronomers and mathematicians
throughout the country looking
for answers to this problem.
And some of this advice
was useless at best.
There's this image on the left.
There's an inventor
named Timothy Clark who
sent Jefferson his design
for a device for finding
the longitude.
And the way he explained
it is that there would
be a plumb line with the
weight that what you would
fix at a particular longitude.
Then as you rolled this
thing east to west,
this line would tilt to
stay gravitationally locked
at your original longitude.
This doesn't work
because there's
no way this could possibly work.
But it shows the extent to which
this longitude question, right,
became this national scientific
endeavor, both for astronomers,
mathematicians, but also for
these tinkers and inventors.
Jefferson had a far
more productive exchange
with Dunbar, who was, in fact,
his most distant correspondent
on this.
The two fine-tuned a method
of determining longitude
through lunar altitude
observations, which
is different than the
usual stellar angle
observations, which we
don't need to get into.
But basically, measuring
the angular distance
from the horizon to
the moon and then
comparing those
observations with those
in a place with a known
time, like the observatory
in Greenwich, where the
zero line of longitude is.
And Dunbar explained
that, quote,
"This method was much better
calculated for travelers
by land than voyagers by sea.
And a single observer with
a good altitude instrument,
though deprived of a
timekeeper, may still
make useful observations
for the advancement
of geographic knowledge."
So all of these things
that Jefferson had
wanted from this method.
So this was a method
that was really created
with a new emerging kind of
American icon in mind, right?
Like one of these guys
like Meriwether Lewis,
these solo heroic explorers
who could go out and figure out
where they were and
make better maps
in this kind of low-tech,
rugged American way,
a distinct American science
for a distinct American empire.
So guys like William Dunbar
and many other astronomers
collected all of this
astronomical data.
Dunbar had built
his own observatory
on his own plantation, in fact.
But all of this data
had to be compiled.
It had to be calculated
and compared in order
to figure out things
like longitude
to comparing observations
in different places.
And one of the key figures
in the United States
in interpreting and calculating
all of this data was
the Spanish astronomer
José Joaquin de Ferrer.
Ferrer had been an officer
in the Spanish Navy
and had served in Spain's
royal observatory in Cadiz.
And around 1800, he
moved to New York,
really bringing this tradition
of Spanish excellence
in astronomy to
the United States.
Ferrer became deeply involved
with the US community.
He became a member of the
American Philosophical Society
in Philadelphia,
and it was him who
really was in charge of taking
all of this raw astronomical
data flowing into the
Philosophical Society,
turning this into useful
geographic knowledge,
things like latitudes
and longitudes
that could be used to make maps.
And he was able to do
this even more precisely
because he was also
tapped into this larger
international network.
He was receiving data from
Spain, from South America,
from the Caribbean, from
Germany, from France,
all of which helped to make
these observations more
accurate.
The more data you
had, the more accurate
your locations could be.
So Ferrer's role in
calculating and synthesizing
this information was
perhaps most clear in 1806
during a solar eclipse.
As William Dunbar had
put it, this eclipse
was to be seen all over
Europe and North America,
and was thus very
important for settling
comparative longitudes.
Basically, you just
figure out the local time
where you see the eclipse in
all of these different places.
Allows you to have a good
comparison of longitudes
from throughout the
whole space where
you could see the eclipse.
Observers from throughout
the United States and Spain
sent their raw data on
this eclipse to Ferrer.
And he was able to
calculate through charts
like this one on the left
where all of these places
were with more precision,
make better maps.
On the third from the
bottom on the left column--
it's hard to see--
it says the forest near Natchez.
That's the plantation
observatory
that William Dunbar kept.
And his observations are
particularly valuable in this
because they were by
far the most western.
The further away, the better,
really, with this stuff.
And this is Ferrer's drawing
of the so-called corona,
the radiation that you
see around the moon
during a full solar eclipse.
It was him who actually
coined this term, corona,
that we still use today,
talking about eclipses.
So perhaps more
importantly, Ferrer
was able to draw
on his experiences
as an astronomer for Spain to
help officials in the United
States figure out the
best ways to use astronomy
to promote this expansion
that they desired so much.
So based on Ferrer's advice,
several astronomers actually
lobbied Thomas Jefferson
that the United States
needed to build a
national observatory based
on the model of Cadiz.
They said this model
was much better
than that of France or Spain.
And this has actually
sort of turned a lot
of our assumptions on our head.
For a long time, historians
have seen Spanish science
as backwards compared to
that of Britain, France.
At the time, though,
people in the US
very much saw this as
the model to emulate.
So in short, I'd argue
that American science
is thoroughly multinational
from the very beginning.
And the fact that historians
have almost entirely excluded
non-Anglos and especially
Hispanics from this story
says a lot more about
modern-day prejudices
than it does about
the conditions
of the scientific
community at the time.
So astronomy is just
one of the sciences
I consider in this book,
"Frontiers of Science."
But I hope that this case
has provided a glimpse
into an intellectual
world that's
just very different
from our usual vision
of early American science.
Again, historians
have usually agreed
that it's this post-independence
context of freedom
and democratic government
that set American science off
on its own path.
But this conclusion really rests
on some very bold assumptions,
even if they're widely
accepted assumptions.
It assumes that US territory
was a place defined primarily
by liberty and democracy.
It assumes that American
people studying nature
were free and
independent citizens.
And therefore, it
tends to assume
that the only truly American
intellectuals were white Anglo
men on the eastern
fringe of the continent.
My book offers a more inclusive,
and I think more accurate,
way to understand knowledge
in the early United States.
This intellectual
world of eastern Anglos
was neither separate
from nor really
all that much superior
to a vaster early America
populated by natives,
blacks, Hispanics, Creoles.
And all of these people
studied the natural world.
But again, it was not
liberty or democracy
that most influenced their
intellectual pursuits.
It was inequality,
imperialism, and violence.
So lastly, I believe that
recovering this broader
vision of American
science matters
far beyond the academic
work of historians.
If American intellectual
history continues
to be told essentially
as the story about Anglos
working in isolation from
the rest of the continent,
it remains really
easy to conclude
that other American
peoples have never
really mattered to knowledge
and culture in America.
And it thus remains really
easy for huge portions
of the population,
including voters,
to rally behind a very
narrow vision of America's
cultural past and
use this vision
to justify ongoing exclusion,
ongoing inequality.
But if scholars
and teachers strive
to elaborate the many, many ways
that multinational encounters
have always been central to
American intellectual life,
then a new set of stories about
which peoples and places matter
to American culture can
then start to become normal.
And more Americans
might then start
to draw on a vision of
history that inspires greater
inclusivity, greater humility.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I have time for questions.
AUDIENCE: Throughout
American history,
there's been waves of
anti-intellectualism.
And a lot of that is, I think,
focused on or personifies
intellectuals as eastern--
what you call fringe
of the continent.
And I was wondering if there
is any sort of relation
between the fact that,
as you were saying,
all these other people
have been excluded
and then if that
plays into that sort
of political
anti-intellectualism.
It just seemed like an
interesting sort of parallel.
CAMERON STRANG: Oh, it does,
and I haven't thought about it
in those terms.
And I think it's a really
great point in terms of
whether or not it's a kind
of resentment at exclusion
or just a sense of--
I live in Nevada
now, and there's
this sense of like, oh, these
effete northeasterners who
think they know better
than everyone else, right?
And I think at least
at the beginning,
this image occurred largely
because these northeasterners
wanted everyone to know that
they were better than them.
Like, there is a very sort of
clear sense of Anglo American
cultural superiority, especially
in these eastern spaces
that was pushed west.
I'd say now, though, it's
less regional and more based
on class in a lot of
ways in that sense.
But yeah, I hadn't
really thought
about this in connection
to sort of resentment
of intellectualism more broadly.
That's a really great point.
Thank you all very
much for coming.
It's been a real pleasure
speaking here at Google.